- I just knew that I
wanted a rap and it was
something that was a hobby.
I just always kept my mind
on focus on the music.
You do everything in life
for the right reasons
then you always going to be good.
I think it's just growth I think it's just
keeping just like moving your ego
out a lot of situations.
(rapping)
- What's that Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability
to do something special
that can change the planet.
So to help you on your
journey today we're going to
learn from rapper Tyga and my take on
his top ten rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
(gentle music)
- I think you know when I was
12 you know, I'm saying like
recording in my room like
you know like I didn't know that I was
going to become a rapper
and make a living off of it
or or meet Wayne and get a chance.
Like I just know I just
knew that I wanted to rap
and it was something it was a hobby.
And I just really never lost the faith.
You know what I'm saying, like
we don't know where we going to be at
like a year from now.
That's what it is this is like
this is knowing but that's
what faith is though right.
To ability the ability
to believe in things
you can't see or touch,
I just always kept my mind
on focus on the music.
- [Man] Good for you man.
- That's my passion
and that's the talent God gave me.
And that's what got me to this point.
For people to even create rumors on me
you know what I'm saying, right.
That's always home base for me,
that's always the foundation is the music.
You got to stay you got
to stay focused on it
you know what I mean, it's not something
that's just for the glitz and glamor.
It's something that you know you got to
really be passionate
about and really commit to
whatever you do.
Anything in life like if
you do things for the wrong
reasons it's going to come out.
- [Woman] Right.
- Bad.
- So if you do everything
in life for the right
reasons then you always going to be good.
- [Woman] The intention is everything.
- Exactly yeah.
That's deep though.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Like he's saying that but it's deep.
- [Woman] Yeah,
- A lot of people do things
for the wrong reasons.
- Yeah.
- And you just sit back
and you know you let it play yourself out.
- I just got to pick
and choose your battles.
- Right.
- Because I got in
started making music to
like be on reality TV.
Or to like.
- Yeah.
- Wake up and have to
address TMZ and see stuff
from my lawyer every day from TMZ.
And I was like, I don't
care about that, like.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean.
I think you just got to
really know, you know,
how to pick and choose your
battles and stay focused
on what your vision is and where your goal
or you're trying to get to.
- Kanye you're like,
yo I need my cash money
a milli a milli a milli.
Are you are you still chasing that
or are you just kind of moving on?
Are you moving on from that?
- Now we just on a new wave.
- New wave.
I see it's money though Tyga, you feel me?
Like it's your money, isn't it?
- It's more money though,
in fact, if I could do
it once I could do it
twice I could do it twice.
- Is that the wave, is that the vibe?
- Do you feel me?
- I like that.
- If I could make one here I can make two.
If I can make two, I can make ten.
You know what I'm saying, I
feel like God put me in this
position to uplift other people
who move forward, you
know what I'm saying?
Like I don't really dwell on the past
but at the same time like
I'm letting people know like
I'm a businessman at the end of the day.
- That's right.
- And this is you know you
got to treat people right.
You know many people put in work
you got to take care of them, right?
And you got to take care of people because
at the end of the day we can't
take it when we leave so.
- Hey man, now what's going on
with cash money, Young Money?
Are you still affiliated?
Like, in a major way, or
are you kind of Tyga now?
- I mean um I'm just I'm just
pushing my brand and that's
what I've been trying.
And so I don't really like
I don't really rely on them
for anything.
- Right.
- You know like I always built my brand
from ground up so.
- Right.
- You ain't playing when you
talk about your brand brother.
- Yeah.
- Everything you wearing is yours.
He got his own gold line out man.
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying.
You got blood diamonds.
- That gold bar.
- Yeah yeah.
- And I brought some it's
my new water right here.
- Pop water, please share.
(laughing)
- Nah, I'm serious.
It's pop water.
- Don't do this to me man.
- What is this?
- You know what Tyga?
(crosstalk)
- In the schools and stuff like that.
So this is like natural
fruit water only 30 calories.
- So it's healthy, it's fizzy.
And is it fizzy?
- Is this your own water for real?
- Is it fizzy like sodas?
Sparkling water?
- Yeah.
- So it's like not just bland.
- Yes.
- It still kind of
tastes like soda a
little bit but it's not.
- It's good for you.
- Yeah, it's good for you.
- This dude came in with his own water.
- His pop water.
(crosstalk)
- Let me see what's going on.
Now there's no alcohol in here, right?
I just took the top off, it smell good
as hell, yeah.
(crosstalk)
- This is apple, right.
- You know after I drink
this down I'm not going to
like grow tattoos.
(laughing)
- No.
- Okay.
- Grow tattoos.
- Yeah hold on, let me read.
And it's not energy water though, right.
- Mmm.
- Okay.
- No energy here.
- Okay here.
I want to keep it real with you.
(laughs)
It tastes like shh.
(laughing)
- This is the apple though.
- You know that ain't right though.
You wouldn't had brought it in if you know
it ain't right.
- No no it's good.
We got different flavors,
apple, pineapple.
- You got to talk to me man.
Clothing line, tennis shoes.
You walk in here with your own water.
- Tennis shoes, tennis shoes.
- Do you know
what I'm saying?
(mumbling)
- Yeah.
- That's awesome, headphones.
- Headphones I brought last time.
I brought the headphones last time.
- You do make music too right?
- Yeah that's awesome.
I mean that's where I
started you know that's.
It was fine, I was like I
always wanted to do like
action and like horror stuff.
- Yeah.
- You know.
So that was for that to
be like my first role,
shout-out to Ferrell
for putting me in that.
It was fun so you know it's just something
that I wanted to really
take serious 'cause I
I got offered a lot of movie roles before.
- Oh wow, okay.
- Like I had I offered
to be on Empire like.
- You didn't do Empire?
- It was, no, because I was like you got
a thing like when people sell
this stuff like you know.
Have you heard of the
Maze Runner, the movie?
- Yeah.
- So I was supposed
to be in it.
- You didn't do that?
- It was a lot of movies up
but I just wasn't focused.
I wasn't where I wanted
to be in my life to where
I just wanted to to act.
- Okay.
- Do you know what I mean?
I'm not going to take on something if I
can't be 100% fully invested in it.
- I get that.
- You know so.
I feel like now is the
right time they do the right
the right roles.
- How do you get to this headspace, pause.
How do you get to the
headspace with the head
and pause and pause what is
it is it is it meditation
is it weed, what do we do?
Is it conversations with your mother?
- I think it's just growth man.
I think is just keeping
just like removing your ego
out of a lot of situations.
- You know I've heard
that I've heard that.
Like remove the ego.
- Yeah cause it's like it's a
time and place for everything
you know what I'm saying.
When I'm on that stage I'm full egod out
because that's my place of comfort
that's my place of like
this is my this is my house.
I think is just something
that's been gone for like
the last couple of years.
Okay, like even in the studio with him
like when he was working on his album,
when he was working on Yeezy.
You know I'm saying?
Like that just in the
studio and just being around
and I think (mumbling)
just me as a person.
You know what I'm saying,
more than anything.
And it just he just watched my vision
he just knows my vision,
you know what I mean?
He's somebody that I
definitely value what he says
you know his vision
'cause he's like a genius.
Like you don't meet some people like that.
They give you that type of feeling like
Pharrell is another person
that's like a genius to me.
Like Wayne lyrically,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like a couple people
that I really like idolize
that are still living,
you know what I'm saying.
Present now that's like
that give that feeling.
And then you know I didn't
never it was never in my
like my plan of my
like to be like they don't want to sign
the (mumbling) one day.
Like I was in my room making mix tapes
listening to Wayne mix tapes, like man,
like I want to rap with Wayne.
Like that was my goal and it happened
you know what I'm saying.
Like it just came into fruition.
But that's what somebody I was like man
be like from any squad I
want to rap with Wayne.
Or like be from like Star Trek because
I used to love like the clips
I used to listen to all that (bleeped)
You know I'm saying?
So like that was like
my two homes that I felt
like, either Pharrell, or like Wayne.
The learning is never over,
you know what I'm saying?
Like as much stuff as I
learned being around Wayne
it's different the things
I learned around Kanye.
And the things I learned from Wayne
I wouldn't have learned along Kanye.
And the things I learned from Kanye
I wouldn't have learned from Wayne.
Make some noise.
(applause)
What's up?
Yeah yeah, woo woo.
(rapping)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Sylex-B De Brainbox asked me to.
If there's someone you'd like to vote on
for the next top ten check out
the link in the description
and go and have your say.
Finally I wanted to give a
quick shout out to Vijai Raj.
Vijai, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book Your One Word
and doing those three
videos on your channel.
I really appreciate the support man
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
- Making you feel uncomfortable
because they want to do
something that's not on line
with your one word is not so
make sure you choose wisely.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- I just always had a passion for some
and I've always been able
to focus on one thing.
So I don't really know how it
feels to hate on somebody else
or just worry about what
somebody else is doing
'cause I'm so focused on my vision.
- Right.
- So I think for
a lot of people it's like
you got to just kind of
find a vision.
- Right.
- You know, everybody's
entitled to their own opinion
you know, for sure.
- Right.
- But it's just some
things you got to just
you just got to be wise about
and just more rational.
I'm still human, you know what I'm saying.
And I still have real problem
just like everybody else
you know and you always want
to be able to relate to people
because when you got millions
of people around the world
looking up to you and you know dressing
like you're talking like you.
- Right right, getting tattoos like you.
- Yeah whatever whatever
whatever whatever in cases
you know I mean you got
to know that you got
it's bigger than just you
and the people around you.
Like you actually have
influence on a lot of people
in the world.
- Isn't that crazy?
- It is you know.
- It's a lot of it's a
lot of responsibility,
what do you think?
- I don't think it's a
lot of responsibility,
but at the end the day you I feel like
knowing knowing that a lot of people
follow me and and look to
everything I do everything
every day it makes me just
it makes me more proud of myself knowing
that I'm that I'm doing
the right thing by them
or you know and uh just influencing them,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm not like I'm not
promoting like negativity.
I'm not promoting like
super dumb violence.
I'm not saying like go kill yourself.
I'm not saying no, like
you know what I'm saying?
I'm promoting like I'm promoting God.
I'm promoting healthy living.
I'm promoting better living.
I'm promoting, you know what I'm saying?
- It wasn't always like that.
It wasn't necessarily like that,
I mean your heart was in the right place.
- It's always been it's
the heart it's always
been in my heart, but at the
end of the day it's like.
Like I came in the game when I was 17, 18.
I saw Wayne when I was 18.
- Very young.
- I'm coming from a place to where like
like you said like not knowing anything.
Dropping out of high school.
You know working at the
mall to like being on tour
with like the the next
biggest rapper in the world.
You know what I'm saying, so it was like
I wasn't focused on the
mission as far as like
you know trying to influence other people.
I was just like in the moment
and I was just fanned out.
So you know when the smoke clears
and I was able to kind of like see his
drive and his passion, apply
that to what I was doing.
- Yeah.
- You know and then
actually get success and
actually see success off of it
like wow this really.
- Sure.
- You know this is this
could really work you know.
And then
then I felt like having
it taken away from me
in a way to where I put
in all this hard work.
People crown me and then
it's almost like they wanted to stone me,
you know what I'm saying?
So they're not.
- Was that what it felt like?
- I wouldn't say that's
not what it felt like.
But it definitely.
- It seemed that way,
- It seemed that way it was like
when it's like yo like I've
always been this great person.
I've always been promoting
positive and like
just mind my own business.
Everybody knows like heard of the blogs
and stuff, you know what I mean?
I just wanted to make
a record kind of like
more inspiring and motivational
you know what I'm saying.
Because like I feel like
you know that blog you
know always attacks me
all the time you know.
But I didn't, but see
I'm not a petty person.
No, you know what I'm saying.
I do things like I said out of spite.
All I got is anger, or nothing like that.
And then like I had the concept already we
had the concept already in
my head I was like, damn.
I really want to take this
and make it like relevant.